This is the same another question from the state person that's there on
eyebrow. So eyebrow is a daily use chemotherapy for breast cancer and some
other female cancers and that definitely is going to affect your liver. So there's
your alkaline phosphatase problem. Also take you monthly insumeta and phosphidex
question I have once again is body order. Again body order is quite often because your body is
trying to detox poisons and these medications though they may be really helping you. So I
not saying don't go on the medication but this is the side effects of some of this stuff. So you're
just going to have to be using a lot of essential oils or something.
Megan started to be on dihydrovermarine and buried my break on hybrids but she's
talked about starting lambidied. Does this sound okay with the protocol I'm on? Yes. So you can't
really go wrong with burmarine. Lambidied I would just say you go slow on it. In Megan does it's not
to go fast on it too. So I can't longpox with her. So